[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome to the mit center for art
science and technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science
of contemporary computation cast was
established in 2012 with the goal of
building and building on
connections between the worlds of art
science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and
as with its predecessors we bring
together artists
scientists engineers and humanists from
within mit and from the world at large
to discuss areas of rapidly evolving
research and urgent
social relevance and defined in that
dialogue
stimulation confirmation provocation
intersection
and we hope common purpose
at mit cass partners with departments
labs and centers to integrate
the arts across the curriculum to enrich
and encourage artistic collaboration
and to provide support to faculty and
members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic
technical and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media we also
look forward to seeing you on friday
april 9th as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
hello um
welcome to the q a for the unfolding
models panel
of the unfolding intelligence symposium
i'm professor of anthropology stephan
helmrich and i'm thrilled to
join you with the three exceptional
speakers for our session
who are princeton university physicist
and professor of astronomy priyan
nadarajan
yale university professor in ecology and
evolutionary biology brandon ogbonu
and glitch artist and resolution
theorist rosa minkman
and i hope you've been able to watch the
really quite riveting presentations over
this last weekend
um before we start up on this hour-long
conversation which i'm really looking
forward to i want to
thank all of the people involved in this
symposium
cast faculty director professor evan
zapporan executive director of arts
initiatives
lila kinney my fellow conveners will
lock it
fox herrell caroline jones i also want
to thank the
cast producers dana heidi leah
catherine susan lydia and harry for all
of the incredible work that they've done
supporting us in this kind of insanely
complex communications and logistics
uh involved in today's event and uh
thanks also to
to drew for providing asl interpretation
today
so much work um i also want to
acknowledge
that mit sits on the uh traditional
unseated territory of the wampanoag
nation traditional stewards of this land
and i want to note too that offering an
acknowledgement like this
through the data clouds and cables
that we're talking through is also to
recognize
all of the computer models of
communication
that subtend the unfolding of our
conversation itself
so unfolding this is a panel
about how tools and computation shape
the models that scientists and artists
make of the universe
the world and of models themselves and i
want to revisit
and frame some of the arguments
delivered by our panelists
whom um if i can i would like to have uh
join me on the screen i think there's
magic that can make that happen
um so just just to kind of refresh
folks memories about our presentations
and set us up for a discussion
priya natarajan told us how she uses
computer simulations to explore
the black hole growth problem in
cosmology
with simulations understood as what she
very usefully calls
playing a mediatory role between theory
and observation a mediatory role
and more as potentially generative of
new explanation
new evidence new knowledge and
prediction
so she argued that simulations may be
approached as a kind of
creolized language for communicating in
domains that are simultaneously
experimental theoretical and
observational
so simulations become tools for
signification
that may be understood as what she is
activating what she calls an
interglot a mix of languages
and interglot this is one of our key
words
interglot uh dr bunu took the analytic
of unfolding
in his paper and really ran with it
making first the connection to protein
folding and protein
unfolding and then to a really i think
inspired connection to unfolding as
disentangling um via darwin's image
famous image of the tangled bank
which then also immediately got us to
the questions of the entanglement of
science and society right um
genetically modified organisms gene
editing etc
and he argued that disentangling
biological process
requires models models like the central
dogma in molecular biology
dna makes rna makes protein
um and models that also have to operate
at the right level
for the question that they're answering
so a model of the covid19 pandemic for
example
will be operating at various levels for
different purposes
maybe a level of protein
expression maybe the level of population
dynamics
maybe to a level that embraces things to
do with social inequality and structural
racism
and he got us to think about how models
as he got us to think about models as
instruments um and also i think
importantly as structures of analogy so
disentangling analogies
we want to think about how models help
us
express analogies but also you know
demand that we disentangle the
analogies that we use um
yeah which analogies do we use i mean is
evolution a game
is evolution an algorithm
those kinds of questions go into
deciding how to model what it is
and rosa menkman tells us that our media
you know the media on which we do
computer simulations
come to us not only with promises to
represent
replicate record and extend
sense experience of the world but also
come to us in a range of formats
cassette tapes a4 paper jpegs
but also in material they come to us in
material manifestations which have their
own limits
limits and their own affordances in
the resolutions that they can offer us
resolutions that are then
animated through the kinds of
compression protocols that are used
for relaying something like an mp3 or a
jpeg
and that can glitch in really
interesting ways that are sometimes
disturbing
sometimes inspiring sometimes productive
and so i think oh and i suppose i should
have one of these for this too right
here we go compression glitch
um
i also have this book glitch feminism
there's all kinds of glitches around my
desk um so we learned
through all of this that computer models
are
interglots they are instruments
they are analogical machines and they
are also dependent
upon standards which are technical
and political standards that
demand particular kinds of compressions
and that produce
artifacts in kind of two senses right
artifacts as things and then artifacts
as
things you don't want so um
and i guess we want to talk about all of
that the way that i want to organize
this conversation
just to start us off and we'll also be
taking questions from
the audience later on but just to start
us off i kind of want to take
each of our panelists in turn and kind
of pose
to them questions that are inspired by
the other panelists
um so if i can i'd love to turn to you
priya
to talk about this really interesting
work you're doing on the black hole
growth problem
in cosmology and thinking about that
through
simulations that mean to
match and scale the observational data
that you have
from various telescopes and to do
and and how they do that using machine
learning algorithms
um but i guess after watching brandon's
presentation um which offers that models
may be seen as
instruments i wondered whether you
thought of interglots
about what you can say more whether you
thought of interglots as themselves
kinds of
instruments so maybe
do that pick that up thanks
thanks um i think um
you know i want to uh first sort of
clarify
that you know when i am talking about uh
simulations
i am setting these cosmological
simulations
apart in many ways compared to other
ways
numerically visualizing data and
processes and equations and so on
and the reason for that um you know as
i've argued um
in the presentation was that um you know
cosmology is a very peculiar field we
cannot perform
any kind of controlled experiments
laboratory experiments or whatever you
what you have in the universe is what
you get so we visually record
and make observations and then we have
to sort of interpret them
in the context of some conceptual model
and these conceptual models used to be
sort of paper and pencil
equations and we're also very lucky that
we have the
ordered physical laws that give us
a structure and the frame to do the
interpretation
and increasingly when you can't do
anything on pencil and paper you've
needed
uh computer simulations and so that's
how simulations were originally seen
as being merely enhancing and
not not regenerative of new discoveries
i
mean
also you know there's the awkwardness
philosophical awkwardness
that you're sitting inside the universe
that you are observing so
there isn't this traditional distance
between the observer
and the observed that you know other
than the quantum
funniness aside in classical physics
that is a very important assumption
because that's tied in with other
concepts like objectivity and so on so
forth right
so here we are we are sitting in the
middle of this universe we're making
observations and there is only one
universe so i can't actually replicate
it either
so in many ways you know cosmology is
not really
a science as traditionally defined
and therefore simulations are play a
very
important role and so and um i've argued
that they play the sort of mediatory
role
of an um and and they are they are
an interglot because they are actually
universal
in the sense that now simulations
allow you to connect models and theories
to observational direct data directly
except there are some limitations as you
pointed out the fact that
we are not able to replicate in our
simulations
you know the exact survey volumes that
are observationally accessible to us
with our telescopes at the moment and
this is where machine learning comes in
and so they've been two instances only
two instances
where simulations have actually been
generative of new knowledge
one is a very interesting instance which
is you know the firm
double negative that did the
visualization for the movie interstellar
so they actually solved einstein's
equipment and what they found
they found and you know kip thorne who
has been working in this field
nobel laureate you know one of the sort
of you know big figures in
understanding uh black hole physics he
noticed
in the visualization that there was a
non-linearity that he had not picked up
before
so there's actually a scientific paper
on which people from double negative are
authors so that's the one
case that i really know where you know a
simulation has been
generative something that was completely
unanticipated unseen before
and the second example is the one that
you know i gushed on about
in my talk where you know we recently
um realized from just looking at
simulations that there ought to be a
very large population of wandering black
holes in the universe
and uh a handful you know one or two
have been found
um because normally we expect all these
black holes to be anchored to the
centers of galaxies like
you know our own galaxy harbors a
dormant black hole and so on
so i think the relationship between
models uh speaking to uh brandon's work
so this relationship between models and
observational data for cosmology is
somewhat apart and slightly different
and you know i would also kind of um
clarify that it's not quite a creole it
is like a universal blood so it's an
interglot in that sense you know creole
is very specific for two target
languages right if i'm not mistaken
so this i'm claiming is much more
universal um
it so happens to um
and as for the kind of untangling that
both
rosa and brandon talked about that you
wanted me to
connect to i think what i found really
interesting
is um the way in which we
conceptualize models whether the um
it's a primary visual uh
representation of the model or i mean
and i think in physics right we have
this
added advantage that we have
mathematical equations that offer
and laws these kind of tight
correlations and cause and effect which
are very clearly defined
so what i found really intriguing is to
hear from
two people in two fields where
causality is not for us causality is a
constraint
i mean you know you know you uh the
cause happens before the effect
and you can actually draw a line and
connect the dots because you have
these principles these universal law of
gravitation etc etc
so it's very interesting to see rosa's
work and
brandon's work where there aren't
necessarily such
clear cut joining the dots
in rosa's case you probably impose that
by hand by choosing to compress the data
decompress and compress the data alter
the resolution
and so on
well thank you for that i mean that
again go
go ahead rosa yeah please i i
enjoy this bridge to uh what you're
talking about and my
in this case i would say it connects
mostly towards the
the blob that i ended the video with
which i use
also as a tool i would say it's a tool
to
not only show how image making works and
a part of that is compression i wouldn't
say that's the only thing like
resolution setting has a lot of stuff
involved whether it's like the ccd chip
or
um the aperture or the amount of energy
invested in the machine that is making
the image right
so in that case this blob is this like
metaphoric latent space for any possible
image and you cut it away and
i think there's an analogy to your
research also where you're
talking about affordances i see these um
these affordances are axes that got the
blob and they cut away
compromises so the compromises are the
images that are no longer
being made because you know you've got
you set a resolution i think you use the
word for that i'm trying to find it real
quick
um do you remember this word that you
used i think it
it was a very interesting resolution
i did um use resolution in a slightly
different
um uh sense in terms of um
when i was talking more about the limits
rosa which i think you also come to when
you're talking about the blog
you are talking about sort of the limits
of understanding of you know what is
possible
and uh that is
input assumptions that's like what i'm
talking about even
that's what you're uh you're saying and
i think input assumptions are a very
interesting way to frame
it's like the same idea but it's for me
i use the word affordance i guess
well maybe i can i can bring brandon
in here um
i'm really interested in this question
that you you brought up brandon about
the level
at which abstractions operate in models
right which you know to use to use
rosa's term just now
involves a set of compromises right in
order to
decide that a phenomenon is made of
particular levels you have to
compromise um so
i wonder if you can speak a little bit
more about that question of how you
think through the levels at which the
models you write
operate maybe i'll just start start
asking to start there i've got more but
yeah yeah yeah yeah no
i think thank you for that question uh
fabulous kind of interaction already
very very fun to explore the the
connections here
i think what's uh interesting and fun
about talking about the levels of a
model question
is that it really does invoke like
domain expertise and the art
part of modeling right that's actually
where the imagination enters it
uh that's where understanding enters it
and this is why
like the notion of simply having
students for example learn
to uh just a suite of mathematical and
in computational techniques
is the end-all be-all to being able to
understand for example
what underlies the covet-19 pandemic
right and this is where a lot of the
problems
of modeling a complex system comes from
is that we don't we we have an infinite
number or not you know a lot of
different tools we can use to examine
phenomenon
but we aren't clear about what the
question actually is
and we you have to be clear about what
the question actually is
to build the proper model to address
that question
right so you know like like i talk about
in the talk with regards to the
electrons in the calculator
let's just take an epidemic for example
i mean i could understand
everything about um you know the way
proteins fold let's just say we
completely solve that problem right one
that's very very kind of modern and
cutting edge
i mean that could tell you absolutely
nothing about whether or not a vaccine
is going to be effective
okay that's a completely different
question right at a societal level
completely different question requires
completely different level of
understanding and requires a different
model in order to address that question
i think we can walk that over into every
single one of these problems certainly
in physics and it's you know it's very
humbling to be on the stage with a
physicist because i think
a lot of the modelers in my field wish
they were physics right the physics envy
kind of concept right i think we've
we've borrowed from this tradition of
being able to understand the world in
terms of a set of
analytical descriptions and what we're
finding is that right
that those are powerful but you do
require this other
dimension and understanding in art and
insight in order to be able to capture a
biological phenomenon in a meaningful
way
um so just to summarize i mean i think
that level of question
is one that is humbling um but i think
that is where like
the creativity the domain expertise uh
you know and study and these types of
things really really do
separate kind of the good models from
the bad ones and we're seeing this play
out in phenomenon
like the pandemic yeah can i ask you
more about that
um you know since since we do have you
here as an evolutionary biologist
who thinks a lot about epidemiology and
its various entailments
how would you classify and evaluate
the levels at which our the covid19
epidemic models are operating
what are the levels oh great question
well great question and i think i think
now as of you know april 2021 i mean i
think all like all of the levels of
models are operating to address
different questions
okay but let's go a year ago i think
it's fun to think about this as a
chronological thing right
because early on we weren't quite
interested in how mutation a and
mutation b were playing together on the
spike protein
and how that whether or not that allows
you to whether that that means the
vaccine will be effective or not
we wanted to know the basic shape of the
epidemic and of course you know this but
anyways even with regards to kind of the
shape and
the wave analogies and these things that
you've pioneered
um we want to know the basic shape like
what is how bad is this thing going to
be
is it how fast before we get to a and b
how long do we need to be under lockdown
those are macro scale questions in order
to understand that you need to know some
kind of gross
properties and the debate about this are
not thing which is now
common knowledge this parameter that we
use to understand how contagious
a pathogen is for example it's now
common analogies
but the idea here is this allows us to
give us
general character and shape about the
way an epidemic looks
and and that allowed us to make big kind
of national and you know social
policies right that's where the debate i
mean really still is there in some ways
right about what we should do when we
should open when we shouldn't but that
kind of defined the early window and
that's one level
at which models are useful right so the
early uk model for example that talked
about you know a couple million dead
and and these predictions that were very
very dire if we don't do anything in a
hurry
i mean that's been kind of debated but
that was at one level i think now
we're at a much different level right i
think or or rather
our models include other levels and they
are about things like whether or not we
can expect the vaccine to be effective
against the uk strain or the brazil
strain or the south right
like those are that's a completely
different question what's
interesting and fun to this point about
intergalacts right
um that three is presentation that what
what an what an amazing term
that i'm certainly going to take with
you know moving forward what a
brilliant way of thinking about it is
connecting these two things
it's connecting the levels and i think
right and so models can allow you to do
that you can build a model that
that about the molecular evolution of
the virus at the protein level
and you can ask a question now about the
way that
how can we think about vaccinology
across the population over the next
several months we can actually build
bridges between these things
so i find that to be kind of we had to
arrive there though it took us time
um i just wanted to make a very quick
point this is just
absolutely fascinating and you know i
think
what is remarkable about um
this panel and the themes um are how
well
all of the different strands uh and
pipes that we all used to think kind of
converge
and so the coveted question for example
for me right
uh from what brandon has outlined and
you know stefan's work and rosa's work
i mean don't you guys think this was one
of uh the
absolute exemplars of the provisionality
of science
like we really don't even know as
brandon said what is the right question
to ask
what are all the right questions and you
know we've
and we've seen all these various
modelers coming in with their inherent
biases
wanting to focus on one particular
question without
realizing that no one question can be
isolated in something like the pandemic
this is a network there are all these
questions that all have to be
tackled together and you know it's not
like you have you know
or there's one equation for spread that
that's all we needed to get and that
would resolve everything
no uh this is a very complex problem and
this is
i thought this was one of those classic
cases where you see the process of
science
and the provisionality we know as much
as we know at any given point
and then we have to as brandon said and
as rosa points out
we have to without limit keep asking
questions because we don't even know
what the right questions are
and which all questions need to be
answered to find
um you know the the solution solution
being
how do we survive this as a globe
i think this is so interesting i haven't
thought about the pandemic in such way
but
i would say what you're proposing is
almost that the pandemic is a
scenario in which uh scientists could
almost have
a a real-life
test scenario in which they can
communicate and exp
and open up their knowledge to the
normal
public which is something people like me
artist
artistic researchers do that's my job
basically
like i do research but i don't convey it
to the scientific community per se i
convey it to
a normal audience that watches art so it
needs to be
like there's um a basic
necessity to make it accessible and
people wanting to access it
and what brandon is also saying like
we're we're missing
kind of a translational aesthetics here
and as you're also pointing out with the
kip
thorne example right where um
uh the the artistic director of a movie
about a
the shadow of a black hole suddenly
finds a piece of science by
showing it through their renders what's
really interesting and what's been
really interesting is that
what i've seen throughout my research is
that there is a very
um deep relationality between hollywood
aesthetics
and the aesthetics of science and
programming right because programming
being a silicon valley and hollywood
being in l.a
those are places that are almost next
door and these people actually come and
visit each other they conversate is this
a study is this way of showing this is
this the proper way to do it and then
there is a
scientific aesthetic exchange this has
been happening but at this point
now we're seeing that um
as you already pointed out that there's
people from all over the disciplines
that all think that their one particular
question is the question to answer the
problem of the pandemic
that they need to voice this and so what
we're seeing is that there is not enough
bridges
there's not enough interglottary
to make problems to voice the problems
in between and research fields right
what i would propose um because i'm
actually quite
worried about just an interglot because
to me it becomes very closely connected
immediately to a new speak of sciences
right because newspeak is just like um
the
1984 reference to george orwell where
they are creating this one language that
takes out all the metaphoric speak
because now we have like
one word to capture a particular state
um this one-on-one idea of
translationism i do hope
and i think that's what you're also for
is that there is still this like
uh metaphoric analogous poetic space
in the interglot and maybe there is like
some space for an extra gloss
in that sense
so i think that um you know uh one
other um interesting uh thread that
i um see in this mention one of the
reasons the pandemic has been so
problematic aside from
the impact on our lives is
the reaction of the public the fact that
you know
the science was evolving in real time
our understanding
limited by the questions as brandon said
limited by the level at which we want to
solve right
and so people are seeing the uncertainty
in science
provisionality and uncertainty right
because you know people were supposedly
baffled right we are saying no mass
today and then tomorrow you're saying
mass like you know we don't know all of
this is changing
and i think this is the peril of you
know
getting into unknown territory moving
into
unknown territory and what are the sort
of
um you know metaphorical connections
and as brandon said the levels and the
kinds of connections that we have to
simultaneously be aware of
and to me it seems like you know for the
pandemic
it might have been you know interesting
to have started off
thinking of this how to approach this
pandemic and modeling it
as a cross-disciplinary adventure right
from the beginning
instead of focusing on the people who
are modeling contagions
providing different models and then the
public health people
are chiming in as a result reacting to
the model
so i'd be curious to hear all of you
talk
about the sort of the reactions to
models right i mean why
why isn't the modeling more integrative
just for a brief just to jump in and i
know there's a lot of coping fatigue and
we don't
we don't want to spend the whole time
you know talking about that example but
i must uh say to connect these points
i think for all the negatives and all
the things that were botched and i've
written a lot about them and i think
priya you mentioned a lot about a lot of
the problems we have
i think a positive example of
particularly where the arts
was very central um for in a positive
response was the flatten the curve
movement
right which was a data visualization
that was created by a data
artist right and and that flattened the
curve became a social justice rallying
cry
it became an epidemiological rallying
cry and it really defined
like the the positive part of the
response
and that was not right uh invoked or
created by scientists at all it was
somebody who was a data visualization
person that ended up driving this public
health campaign so i think to the point
you just made three uh
that's like a good example and that is a
model like there's no numbers
in it but it is a model right in the
ways that we talk about and it is a
model certainly the way that
rosa has mentioned with regards to how
the arts can drive and kind of reframe
how we can
think about uh complex problems
i would expand yeah i would expand that
to include it as an interglot
that kind of synthesis
yeah i mean thanks for bringing that up
brandon because i was going to think of
precisely following rosa think about
right the politics and the possible
pitfalls of
aesthetic productions of scientific
knowledge in visualization
the curve has done a lot of really good
work but it also obscures things
right i mean it obscures the
multiplicity of curves
it did for a while i think for many
obscure the
radically different experiences
different communities had
where one had to realize there are many
many curves happening
and and some of the curves are
revelatory of
things like structural racism
underserved public health infrastructure
things like that um so
but i think that's super interesting to
think about the
to think about that piece of scientific
visualization as a
as as producing an aesthetics that does
and does
not surface particular kinds of matters
of concern
i want to get back to aesthetics and ask
rosa um
a question about
um about
aesthetics and i want to ask you
what your experience was of of watching
the talks by priya
and brandon in terms of that what kinds
of aesthetic
um trends did you see kind of coursing
through the way
they presented their talks what kinds
maybe you have some kind of glitch radar
what kinds of glitches did you see
that might possibly leap into their work
um
unannounced or things like that
if that makes honestly i didn't see any
glitches uh also i have to say like i
i appreciate glitches um i think
we are uh diluting the word glitch a
little bit here a glitch would be like
an unexpected break from a
an expected flow or a functional flow
um of course in like popular culture
this has become something more stylized
and it's been taken out of that
technological definition
and now it's become like a you know a
language a visual language of its own
when i looked at brandon simply as a
presentation
i don't think there was a lot of glitch
there whatsoever not from the stylized
form and definitely not
what i can say for a scientific point of
view
you guys are perfect however
the aesthetic form yeah i mean maybe
another
term to to put in here is standards i
mean what kinds of standards did you see
you know animating the way the work had
to be kind of held together
well what i like about
priya's presentation but maybe that says
more about me than about
um scientific well maybe not uh when i
was go
going through her slides again i
recognized a lot of the images that i
use in my own presentations there was
one slide that you had
three different images one was from um
the big bang and the time mapped after
it there was the shadow of
a black hole and another image
and in my last presentations i've been
using
those particular images point blank like
so um what i'm starting to see is that
they're like these tropes or like
images that are maybe overused they
become not just
um uh in illustration they become
the illustration and that's actually
dangerous right because then we
consider a black hole or the shadow of a
black hole in this case
to always have this like particular
floopsies of
energy or whatever it is um and
i think that is dangerous because
maybe black holes are not at all this
round or
and also because these are simulated
images in the sense that they have
given been given color or whatever so
for the
non-uh educated scientific
interested person they might actually
open up um just a standard and
standardized aesthetic
that makes them misunderstand that these
things are
much more wide in variety and that a lot
of these things can be
colored differently be understood
differently
basically that what you're looking at
are like uh energy waves or
sound waves rather than you know a color
a shadow i don't know like
whatever so that's a dangerous operating
nerve
yeah very important point you make rosa
and
stefan for guiding her to that i think
that these images are meant to structure
our imagination but there is a fear that
they may limit our imagination and we
have to watch out for that
yeah and i have something to add to that
maybe uh when i was at cern where i did
my collide at cern residency
i was really looking for imagery
aesthetics of particle physics like
research into the smallest tiniest bits
and what i found was that there was
actually very little artistic
interpretation of those places
all you see are just the the events
in like a collision diagram or just
numbers and i was wondering
a lot of the times why is there so
little artistic interpretation in a
place like cern
and what i finally um my conclusion was
finally that we don't actually have a
lot of movies taking place at the
particle physics level
so there is not that like influx of
money of uh you know artistic directors
of
research into how to make open up this
space
to another audience which
has again both positive and negative
consequences right
but so um when i was there actually i
believe it was also kiptorn
who came to visit because he was going
to make a movie about
tiny uh superheroes or something i don't
know
but that was really funny to me because
i think it's like one of the first times
they had
a hollywood director going to do
research on the tiny stuff
which is something that there's not a
lot of
imagination about that that we all have
to imagine by ourselves
somehow well i think you know in
astronomy we have the advantage
thankfully that the sky belongs to
everyone
and we all have experience uh we don't
have to do much
just existing looking up you know being
upright as homo
sapiens we've had access so i mean
there's a connection that
anybody and everybody can make to our
visual uh
images right and there isn't the same
kind of
visceral connection and access you know
a child growing up in kenya looking up
at the night we'll see a better sky
actually than we do in new haven
for instance but um you don't have the
same with particle physics there's a lot
of
layers of interpretation computing
models many layers of many unfolded and
folded models that lie between
us and that representation of data from
particle accelerators
[Music]
and also to use rosa's terms again there
are compromises built into
the kinds of theoretical commitments
that you want to make in the model
right um i want to um i want to make
sure we get some
time to get questions from our our
audience and i have a couple
here um maybe i'll start with one
to to brandon we have a question
i'll read it it says you shared that
abstractions and metaphors are how
incomplete models could be generative
in your observations would these poetics
be challenging for scientists to grasp
what are your recommendations for young
scientists to enhance competence
in using abstractions and metaphors in
modeling
that's a great question um you know
i think i think the challenge here
i mean is the way that we teach science
and how that is incompatible with a lot
of the ideas
that i talked about with regards to how
you know abstractions can be generated
right
we're taught we teach people kind of the
analytical tools to be able to
understand the way of
in in physics class the way a pendulum
you know is swinging or something of
that nature which is a really important
thing to understand because those are
kind of fundamental forces of the
universe
the problem is that everything that is
interesting will not be
neatly described by those types of
equations
that way and a great example and one
that i think of when i connect with
rose's work
um is the whole problem of modern
genetics
is one where we have a complicated
mess of genetic information interacting
with environments and all these
essentially infinitely complicated ways
to create me standing here
at one of my six foot let's just round
up to six foot one
right um and the idea is that that
is that that is composed of all of this
information
interacting right in this way and i
think we're limited in that way
by the manner in which we have built
scientific knowledge which is one plus
one equals two
to right and everything is kind of very
linear and structured
when in fact it's this blob it's this
tangled bank
it's all of these complicated things
that are interacting
in one way so what i would say is how do
you actually address that
it's that we really need you know i
think the easy answer is like
liberal arts education right or
something like that but i think much
more nuanced than that
the best models do not require numbers
and this is what i say it starts
conceptual
and artful first it doesn't matter how
complicated the problem is
whether or not it is schroedinger's cat
and i don't know how priya feels about
that so
you know maybe you don't like that
analogy but the point is it's been it
has been useful for people to think
about a complicated problem
whether it's the pun and square which is
an analogy whether it's the central
dogma which is an analogy whether it's
these you know whether it's another one
the pre-op i want to hear you talk about
the uh
what is it uh the nicholson morally
whatever these
i think we really need to teach how to
abstract reasoning
independent of numbers or even
scientific principles at first
and then use that to kind of build
scientific knowledge on top of
i practice this in my research program
and i think it would be
this is kind of useful uh for young
people
well thank you so much for that that
that really connects well to a question
that's come in for rosa
you know precisely about non-numerical
representation the question is about
narratives
so this is a question from one of our
viewers
um to rosa and it reads
narratives seem to be prominent in your
practice
could you further elaborate how
narratives have helped enrich your
artistic research
especially in exploring your subject
matters that are often quite abstract
resolution and data or even non-existent
this is your work about impossible
images
how would you describe the role of
narratives for you in formulating
challenging
expanding computationalist and
representationalist models
yeah um i have a two-fold answer to that
and one part i have actually already
covered but
um when i was talking to scientists at
cern
one of the scientists told me that to
her actually science is the challenge of
finding
things out and the pleasure of
understanding but then of course
as i'm an artist and i'm not writing a
diary
or you know just doing research in my
head until i make a paper
i want to put it into
legible or understandable information to
my audience okay cool
but then there was the second part is
where when i was visiting because that's
the beauty of this cern award that i
received
is that i didn't just get to be at cern
and talk to all the scientists there
which was
amazing i talked to 40 scientists and i
realized that there are
many types of particle physicists there
is not just one
every every particle physicist by
themselves already use another language
to talk about the same things and that
depends if they're like philosophical or
more mathematically
uh geared but to me as a newbie
as somebody that is definitely not of
that realm it became really hard to
follow their language and to
learn to probe what to be able to expect
from them right and then it turns out
okay they have not one or
four big experiments no actually they
have hundreds of experiments
and all these experiments they perceive
stuff
through a technology cool how do they
perceive stuff
they watch something whether it's a wave
whether it's
light whether that's or light wave or
whether it's a sound or whether it's
an energy thing i don't know like they
watch all this stuff going through
something whether it's a magnet or a
lens an optical lens
they watch it through something they
probe it through something and then
something comes out
but some of these people they try to
dump it down for me and try to make it
understandable and i talk about it as
photographic
machines and then when i come to the
next scientists they get very
upset if i say oh so this part of the
camera is the lens they're like this is
not a camera
so what i realized is that not just does
every scientist have their own
language these machines they also um
are generally
called i don't know how to say it like
referenced to by different names
and what i really enjoyed by both priya
and brandon is that
priya you used um messengers
and i would say those messengers they go
through a window that's like the
the probing mechanism right whereas
in brandon's talk you use the word
actors and operators i'm not entirely
sure if i can conflate
your two researches through that but in
my
imagination if we have a latent image
space or just a latent image
or a latent space of perception
or whatever it is um then
there are at least these two but now
with machine learning it gets more
complicated of course and that's very
interesting to me but i don't know how
to expand on that yet
but you get these like window messenger
kind of situation
in every one of these scientific
spaces and that refers again to your
interglot yeah
but also maybe to brandon
i don't know if that's a good answer to
you but that's
it makes me wonder about visual
interglots
maybe this um one of the people asking a
question
to us revisit something we've discussed
a little bit but i think is worth more
discussion
for priya they write you've described
the profound potential of simulations
and cosmological studies the simulated
images you showed are indeed very
stunning
do visual parameters if visual
parameters in your simulation serve both
functionally and aesthetically how do
you decide on the determination and
altering of visual elements
in your simulations like colors scales
textures even visual effects and
animation
and how do they affect the modeling
results
um yeah i'm thinking too of you know um
rosa's talk
pointing us to things like the the
latent histories of
race in color photography right which
tells on
you know the very chemistry of the way
that
film operated in the mid 20th century so
what about
the visuals that you give us the the
colors of the black holes etc
yeah right so um yeah that's a that's a
great question
um and i think that there are choices
that are made that are very specific
choices
and uh that are made and so you know
there is a
intentionality behind those choices and
often uh it it they are optimized
for as i mentioned for familiarity
so because these are very esoteric
abstract kinds of objects you know that
you can't quite
reach out and touch and so there's a
there's a way in which
part of the exercise is to make it
intelligible and accessible
that is a to a visual palette that
anyone and everyone
can kind of appreciate so you know the
fundamental colors of
heat the fact that it's white hot red
hot and yellow so that sort of black
body spectrum
sort of informs many of the choices and
some of them
and some of the visualization is also
scientifically driven
in terms of the phenomenon that i want
you to
draw your eye to and attention to so
what do you choose to show as dynamic
because one of the problems in all these
simulations
and is the number of enmeshed embedded
time scales and spatial scales that are
all kind of
lumped together and you know in the
universe when you go out at night and
you see
uh you know a little wispy galaxy nearby
you're seeing a two-dimensional
projection of it right
and the advantage of a simulation is
that we can give you the experience of
you know dancing around
it and seeing it in 3d which you never
ever
see right so it's a reconstruction so
it's a simulation
um in the in the sort of the dictionary
word if you go and look up the word of a
simulation there's something about
fakeness make believe that is part of
that so
there's that little bit of that element
but i wanted to come back to this larger
question that everyone has addressed so
beautifully uh stefan
which you know you pointed out to which
is i think we need a sort of a new kind
of lexicon
and you know i am my personal obsessions
are with mapping and so i think you know
we don't as brandon said
and rosa said we can have a new we can
we can come up with new kinds of
alphabets i mean they don't
it doesn't have to be mathematics it
doesn't have to be
uh you know pre uh models that already
exist we can really think of new
kind of ways of um it seems if you look
at any problem now
the it's not so much the problems are no
longer
you know you can't parse them into
linear bits it's all about
networks and interconnections so i think
we need a new lexicon that will allow
you to map
connections i don't know what it is i
mean
for people like rosa to help us help
people like brandon and me to figure out
what might be sort of optimal ways
of getting people to think
um you know both pedagogically and
otherwise
what might be new ways of
you know visual clearly uh because of
the appeal
universal appeal of visual elements
although i also i would argue i i also
think of color blindness or thinking of
the different kinds of affordance
right or the fact that luminosity and
saturation don't track
the same in black and white versus in
color and so all these interesting
confusions can happen when you move from
you know one coloring
regime to another um but i'll step back
and brandon
you know and the whole sort of inherent
um you know the whole idea of you know
in science a lot
of these iconic methodologies you know
there have been a very small set of
people
uh who have been able to do science who
have got to define science have gotten
to define the symbology of science
and the question is in converging to
universals there's always a danger
that we are drowning out the
multiplicity
and the uh and the the creative
energy that uh you know different kinds
of
individuals different kinds of systems
bring so i think
that is the challenge of our times how
do we
actually move away from
restricted visual symbolic
languages i i don't know that brenda
wants to add some
anthropologists but i i just want to say
maybe what you're both getting at is
that um
most of our audiences have become too
lazy
because they're so used to established
vernaculars and establi
established imagery for particular
things so maybe what we need is more
dynamic
interpretations and i'm also thinking
about like
um the materiality so not just
referencing
materials but also using materiality as
a signifying
strategy right so to create kind of like
multi multi-layered folkloric
vernaculars
to translate scientific
imagery that is not static
maybe like an information yeah an
informed material vernacular
i would say yeah an exaggeration
things come to mind yeah i mean this is
really what made me converge on this
uh obsessively on interglot you know
it's there's something
there that i feel that it has so
many dimensions in which we could you
know
uh mine that metaphor
yeah my dream the statement of the
forked tongue i just want to put that in
there because that's such a nice word
for that
where while you have like one layered
imagery you could fork it all the time
for tongs
you know my dream for the way that i
want to go about this
problem just personally is i mean you
know this is the dream right
for every single scientific discovery i
could tell a story about
it right like put it into kind of a
story form because that's a
that is a non-visual but very universal
uh kind of right folkloric i heard right
uh i would be able to also create a
visual piece of art around
it which is right and also be able to
gamify it and somehow that's when we
haven't talked about it's another
kind of unit that's another largely
universal that's debatable
i'll ask anthropology apologies the room
whether or not gamification is truly
universal
but but i think you know there are
certainly arguments of that and so what
i'm saying is
i wonder if this interglace if all of
these different possibilities could live
like i don't see these things in
contention i think you can have
something kind of raw
at the middle of an interval but it can
be adapted
right for kind of whatever the
constraints or needs or availabilities
uh the of of where that science needs to
be kind of translated
we're running toward the hour but i want
quickly to
give you guys an opportunity to ask each
other super quick questions
i mean what kinds of things came up for
you that that we haven't surfaced yet
just you know if we can
offer something go ahead let me know
yeah just
for me okay i'm gonna go ahead
well just for me the uh i'm just
doubling back to
looking at rose's uh presentation and
seeing and reading rose's work
um just how the basic question of how
we're even imagining
the relationship between the information
and often in the in the visual sense in
your work rosa
how that kind of comports very neatly
over to biology i mean we
we aren't even thinking about the
problem of what a phenotype is correctly
which is why we're never ever getting
after very neat and clean genetic
answers for right for even diseases i
mean we're getting
interesting information but it's not as
simple as we thought and it's in part
because we're thinking about the problem
in a broken way
not unlike the way that you've
constructed your resolution kind of
problem
in in the visual in other contexts so um
so that's just something i kind of
highlighted that i thought really was
interesting i'll stop there
yeah but i think we have to give props
to um stefan
here because i think what he did is he
created a really nice panel
in which priya me and you we kind of
have this like
i wouldn't say like flow between us but
of course priya is researching a
particular thing
and so she's finding trying to find
models whereas you're like reverse
engineering
also to see how things have become
something
and then me personally i'm trying to
like
establish this like a tool to see how
you can make
things or how you can make maybe
problems and redefine
uh ways of seeing uh so i see that
that's how that came about yeah
so thank you stefan thank you
yeah thank you as well
i mean i guess the um only question that
i had was
about how do we we are all united in our
ambition
of what we want i think for um
the science for science society culture
and so on
but i'm curious about you know should we
really aim for universals you know this
is the question that i
you know and i would really like stefan
to weigh in
as an anthropologist where you've looked
at you know you look at multiplicity and
you're not
you're not as focused on finding the
explanation for something right
oh that's a difficult question priya
thank you for that
yes i mean so much of cultural
anthropology is precisely about
demonstrating that
things that people think of as
universals are parochial
and have histories and you know there's
various ways
into that you know we can think about
histories of color
we can think about histories of genes as
holding information
and we can unwind all of those things
and unwind the universality of those
claims
and we are unwind we are winding up
uh the time i see there's a clock
flashing at me here and i just want to
thank you all three so much for this
incredibly wonderful conversation
and for the superb just absolutely
superb presentations
uh you recorded for us here at cast and
mit
and just thank you so so much everybody
no thank you to all of you thank you
that was absolutely
a real privilege pleasure yeah amazing
privilege indeed thank you and thank you
stefan
are we off camera now are we is this the
lunchroom
you